[Musique]
cap et chapeau melon
c'est ainsi que daniel hechter couturier
le 23 ans voit les lycéennes aujourd'hui
d'une collection insolite qu'il a
présentée dans la rue en compagnie d'une
consoeur martin grand bal qui elle
habille les amis on retiendra qu'à 16
ans le pull à col roulé ne sera plus
incompatibles avec le deux pièces
classiques mais à la vérité les
collégiennes n'ont pas attendu que la
mode leur arrive tout près elles ont
déjà fait elles mêmes leurs moeurs il
suffit pour s'en rendre compte
d'assister à une sortie d'un lycée
parisien à hassine comme elle vise ou à
molières de 13 à 17 ans on a des idées
qui ne sont pas celles de la grande
soeur et on les exprime pour commencer
on a emprunté les bretelles de papa unis
du radier en élastique en cuir ou en
tissu
elles ont éliminé les ceintures du
grenier on a sorti une ancienne trousses
de médecins de campagne pourra faire un
sac
[Musique]
les bottes plus haute se portant d'un
orné d'une chaîne concurrente avec les
chaussures plates
les jupes sont relancés cours la grande
folie les chaussettes emprunter ou frère
a sorti des chaussures cyclistes
et bien sûr on ne lésine pas sur les
bijoux les colliers sont faits d'une
quantité de chaînes très fine plus en
porte de rang lui c'est beau les
coiffures gonflante ont disparu la vague
eto'o ne poser comme des papillons sur
le sommet du crâne et elle est la
nouvelle élégance des moins de 17 ans
qui fait fureur ont sans doute avec ces
tendances générales et variations de
détails
c'est ainsi qu'aux chaînes collier
s'ajoutent volontiers en sautoir la
montre et l'alliance de grand mère reste
que le sacs sacoches le gros bracelets
au bras le pantalon type marin qu'on
appelle du reste la marine est les
bottes les chaussettes les chaussures
cyclistes et jupe à bretelles
constituent les éléments clés d'une
hotte qui ne suis pas à la mode mais
dont les créateurs de mode devront
finalement tenir compte c'est la
revanche des moins de 16 ans
[Musique]